sorry for the romantic question but i
talked to dan gable and uh he always
looked to the russians as um
as the artists in wrestling
and uh he always wanted to be an artist
but i think he's known for being that
sort of uh guts aggression mental
toughness guy but he always was drawn to
the artistry of wrestling it's hard to
know when you just
watch you because it looks like you're
aggressive and you got the guts and the
mental toughness but there's also
obviously a mastery of technique which
would you lean towards in terms of
what accounts for your success and just
the way you approach judo is it the
the guts the aggression the mental
toughness
and or is it the mastery of technique
the artistry
mine would be my
my aggressiveness if i'm gonna pick
those two areas
um
but i think there's a third area in
there that i would put myself in where
i'm more of a strategist
i look at all of my opponents
and
all i ever see is their faults
and the way i do judo is built around
their faults
and it's just i put myself in scenarios
where i don't even know how i'm going to
win
but what i've done in those scenarios is
i've made it very difficult for you to
win
and then i figure out the rest as i go
like how do you study an opponent
are there bins you can put them in like
there's a lefty and a righty or yep that
this kind of stuff how many bins are
there in judo in your mind that you put
your opponents in
yeah there's probably about 20.
there's like certain players who you
could put in a category of like
they're only good for the first you know
two-thirds of the match
after that they turn into a different
player where they're either falling into
a sense of panic
or uncertainty and you can if you were
to take a video clip of let's say
church's philly right they got george
and i beat in the olympic semi
he's somebody that would beat you in the
first three minutes
and if you clipped out all of his
matches and you only watch the first
three minutes of every match you would
see one style
if you found all the matches where he
got taken into the last minute
and he wasn't winning by a
major score
you would see a completely different
fighter
and so going into like my olympic semi i
put him into that category of like i
want to get to this guy because this guy
is beatable
the trick is how do you get there how do
you get there and by the way we're
talking about the 2016 olympics where
you won the silver medal you're part of
three different olympics but the
cardio
aspect of it
have you faced exhaustion often in your
matches where you have to go deep and go
like past
yeah but that's not from
the judo side of it that's from like i
did a very bad job of making weight
there's always the weight cut yeah it's
always the weight cut
and i think people really struggle
with that they blame cardio and training
and everything else but
when it really comes down to it like we
train for an hour and a half two hours
twice a day
how are you tired after five minutes
right right it becomes into a mental
struggle your anxiety your stress your
lack of belief in yourself
or in my case sometimes it's poor
nutrition
sometimes i add one too many mcdonald's
meals it just
it happens
you